hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational yesterday we've
covered five games between Magnus Dawson
Hikaru Nakamura Magnus was able to win
the match in in Armageddon and now we're
gonna check out what happened in the
match between our eyes of Fallujah and
the Dingley rain so in the first game
ali reza has the white pieces well this
is the second game actually the first
game ended in a draw they had a nice
opposite car bishop end game so i
decided to skip that one as i decided
i'm only going to show decisive games
mostly so this is game 2 now our razor
has the white pieces let's see let's see
how it goes so ali reza opens with efore
and it's a very interesting dink
most likely surprised I'm already on
move one because dink went for c5 the
Sicilian and he's not really a Sicilian
player and especially since Fallujah
just defeated Magnus Carlsen in the
battery blitz Cup with his Knight to c3
and this is what he tries against the
ding here but as being is probably aware
of the games that were played in the
bathroom blitz Cup he was ready for the
Knight to c3 reply so the six we have
Knight to have three nights but f6 by
dink and now before I just transposing
into the normal stuff C captures Knight
captures we have a six and now Bishop to
e3 the the English attack against the
night off we have E 5 by dink
pushing back the knight Knight b3 and
Bishop to e6 now f3 strengthening the e4
pawn so now maybe you can shift the
night over to d5 and here instead of
just normally developing with Bishop e7
or Knight bTW 17 first throws in a nice
h5 move to maybe throw Fallujah off
guard and it will make it somewhat
harder for him to start expanding on the
King side in the future so Queen d2 he
prepares the Castle queenside and now
comes Knight B to d7 at some point this
Knight wants to come to c5 we have
castles by future and Bishop to e7 King
b1 always a useful prophylactic move and
now as Singhal most likely Castle
kingside and futures already castled
Queen side b5 now you want to start with
the expansion on the Queen side you want
to put b4 go rook c8 end of
attack the white king so a3 preventing
b4 for the moment and rook the c8 and
there are a few games in the database
for Bishop to g5 an h4 were played but
h3 is a new move by Perugia I so it is
as a move 13 that we have a completely
new game and this is basically where our
game starts so dink pushes h4 makes it
difficult for a fugitive execute the g4
in the future
and now f4 dings King is still in the
center of the board so it makes sense to
open up the position and it puts strain
on e5 so it will make it difficult for
black to execute the d5 anytime soon so
being castles and now fallujah continues
with f5 this is a very committal move
yes it does win the bishop pair however
it gives dink
some clear targets on the Queen side so
here the characters on b3 c captures on
b3 and now as the b3 point is undefended
now tonight the c5 basically forcing the
trade here so Bishop captures D captures
now adding spawn structures of course
much better as it usually is in the
Sicilian so ding wouldn't of course mind
trading Queens here and fallujah
declines while attacking the h4 pawn and
thing just goes Queen to c7 he says I
just want to play b4 here open up the
Queen set even further and I'm claiming
you do not have time to grab the age for
pawn since you might run into some
discoveries maybe 95 is an option you
have to calculate a lot of things before
I'm sorry before grabbing a pawn like
that so here a future instead decides to
grab it but safely by playing g4 he
allows HP after sin g3 and Poisson which
will open up the G file of course Dean
doesn't want to allow g5
so he has to play H chapters and g3 on
Poisson we have Queen captures and now
rook F to d8
just bringing the other work into the
game as well Bishop to e2 future
connects rooks and now brush up to f8
this bishop will be very useful here
guarding the the g7 pawn and now the
best choice for white of course push h4
you want to play h5 h6 and open up the
black King and the ding says yeah that's
that's very nice but I'm just gonna play
the the car
Queen to b7 and I'm gonna go after your
pawn here and okay
Queen g2 if you lose your defense it and
now rook to d4 a going for the pawn yet
again and here you have to decide
whether you want to keep defending it or
do you want to eliminate one of the
attackers but capturing here doesn't
really do all that much for black since
after you capture you've already created
a nice pass pawn here the Knight has to
move you've removed one of the defenders
of the Queen side and it's just not a
good position for white so instead
Fallujah doesn't does he doesn't enjoy
Bishop to f3 Bishop to f3 is very very
passive it's an ugly square for the
bishop then B 4 is coming and maybe you
kind of want to keep this Bishop here
for example if before sometimes in the
future after all this clear maybe you
can play Bishop the c-4 to create a
barricade barricade here but okay now
fallujah decides that he's not
interested in in a passive move like
Bishop to f3 he continues with the
attack h5 and okay
King says now it's time to grab the pawn
and Knight captures on e4 and now dink
pins the night Bishop to f3 but not
really because Knight captures on c3
with check we have B captures on c3 now
attacking the rook and here we reach the
position from the thumbnail dings rook
and Queen are under attack so well being
could just trade rooks here and then
move the Queen ding prefers efore as
efore forces the creation of the of the
past pawn on DF file so you have to play
C capture son before we have C chapters
on d4 and now pawn captures on f3
attacking the Queen Queen g4 and now
Queen to d5 centralizing the Queen
attacking the b3 porn while defending
the f3 pawn and here at being is down
the exchange but he does have a very
nice attack here so if you lose your
defense rook to d3 I'm just keeping an
eye on the 3rd rank and now c4 ding bust
open the position however it gives
fuchsia this very nice defensive option
of Queen captures on f3 and he plays it
now you cannot capture the rook because
the Queen is hanging so here
Queen back to d6 now attacks the a3 pawn
but now beat characters and c4b captures
on c4 and rook
see three just not allowing this pointer
to go any further we have Queen captures
on d4 and now we reach the critical
moment of the game
Fallujah still up the exchange but his
King is very much wide open and you have
to be very careful how you how you
continue here basically the only good
move for white is King to a tube but
it's not easy to figure out why this is
the only good move for white especially
when you're low on time so if you lucha
plays rook h the c1
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning idea for ding
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on figuring out that
it's worked to be a trek as I said that
King to a2 is the only good move for
white and for those who just want to
enjoy the show yes it is but not worked
to be it checked right away but Bishop
captures on a3 and now there are a lot
of problems here because if you capture
it for example rook captures on a3 then
you get rook to b8 check and now King c2
just you deliver mate and that's that's
just it so that's the problem
however fallujah went look 1 2 c2 and
here dink continued with bishop back to
e7 he was also a long time and he didn't
want to over calculate even though rook
to b8 is still winning here for example
King a 2 and now you just go Queen to b6
with the idea of Queen B 1 check for
example if you capture on e3 this is
made and if Queen defends the back rank
I just Bishop to b2 you block the B file
and now Queen a5 fall back winte one
will be checkmate
but ding is dings position is better
he's he doesn't want to spend too much
time calculating he just goes back
Bishop to e7 and okay Queen b7 by future
with a double attack here being defends
with Queen to d8 and now Rock the D - of
course you cannot capture any captures
results in the loss of the Queen so look
the d2 attacks dings Queen hoping for
characters and then captures and see it
with check but now Queen the f8 with
ideas of maybe going Russia before
winning the rooks here so King to c2 and
now comes the bush
to f6 instead Bishop to b4 also possible
but being decides to go for Bishop to f6
just putting more pressure on the rooks
and here fuchsia doesn't have all that
much all that much to do
rook to b8 if you remove the road and
just rook to b8 fall by rook to be to
not really much going on there so rook
to d7 here fuchsia
tries to tries to get being to capture
on c3 so he can go for rook captures on
f7 we're of course if you capture them
you just lose the rook with check and
then King captures here of course you
don't want to do this but after King the
Queen to c5 it's still winning for black
but it's it's an ugly position to
calculate that the bishop is still
guarding here and after King captures
now Queen 85 check and you were slowly
but surely checkmate the black King
wherever he goes you cannot go to the B
file because of just a winning the Queen
and if you go here in the recoil very
quickly deliver some deadly blows so
after rook d7 I think went looked the b8
first and now we have Queen to c7 but
now that the rookies on the B file
ding goes for the for the very nice
Bishop characters on c3 and now the same
idea doesn't work with rook captures on
f7 because of just rook the B to check
you give up the bishop and then after
Queen before check white is getting
checkmated so after Bishop captures on
c3 we have King captures on c3 and now
Queen to b4 with check King to d4 we
have Queen to d2 with check King to c5
and now rogue b5 check forcing a capture
on c4 rook King captors on c4 and now
Queen to c2 check with King to d4 and
now while you could we go around with
the rook and the Queen and try and
figure out if there's a meeting net here
ding goes for the one option that he
knows that winning and that of course is
Queen captures on c7 he just straight
wins and goes into a winning endgame
rook captures on f5 and it was in this
position that ali reza fallujah resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here ding is up two pawns and even
if you attack one of them a5 defends
this pawn you're gonna win this point as
well you're gonna be up three points and
of course it's completely winning
fallujah knows that there is no point in
playing this again sting so that's a
game to thing takes the lead in the
match
and we're gonna see what happens next
can future equalize and who will who
will be the winner of this particular
match so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Andrea
Grymes Barbados Bellagio pompon yup and
Paul need him Eric Armani and short and
crammed for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing coverage of the Magnus
Invitational thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Sunday